yeah and we we seem to believe now that
being
famous or being a public figure for a
lot of people they they crave it because
they believe that it will sort their
problems out
that once they become famous it will be
act as a you know medicine for
whatever ills that they have in this
life but as somebody
who you know is in the public eye but
has seen your dad catapulted to this
stratospheric level of fame you must
have seen the other side of it
yeah it was just completely absurd like
honestly i mean
i think that the reason he got so
sick was pretty much purely because of
this
this was a benzodiazepine acatheia
caused by a psych med
like a lot of people have said was it
all the stress that he was under was it
because he did you know he did like 130
city tour in 200 days he was like flying
every day he was doing
lectures at night like he was on fire
and then my mom got sick
and this acatheisia started from these
benzodiazepines
and that nailed him right like the
the illnesses hurt him i don't actually
think it was
the fame that hurt him now at the
beginning
when when there were questions about him
losing his job
and he was very worried about that that
was a very stressful time or when there
were protests when he was going to
universities
that was really stressful so that was
2017 and that's
part of the reason he actually started
taking the anti-anxiety medication
other than the fact there was ssri
withdrawal was all that
stress but then when he kind of started
avoiding
universities and started touring it was
overwhelmingly positive
so he's had it's been overwhelming but i
wouldn't say that his experience has
been negative
in the whole like when we get people
approaching him on the street
their 99 of it is
is positive so um it certainly doesn't
make your life less complicated
it doesn't make it simpler like it's not
like you get famous and then you get
more money
for no reason uh and then
you're happier but you know what happens
i think
is if you get to a certain level of fame
then you're presented with
a ton of opportunity and if you grab
those opportunities
then you can make money so it's not just
because you're famous it's because
you're working
but you do have more access to
opportunity and then i think that can go
in
whatever direction but it certainly
makes more people hate you no matter
what you do
and it doesn't make your life any
simpler it's definitely
stressful yeah it's interesting because
i had an experience a couple of years
ago where
i was in every newspaper in the country
for a week
just a week and then it was over it was
over right
and it wasn't necessarily particularly
critical or whatever
most of you know all a lot of the
stories were positive a lot of the
comments were positive etc but
he was unbearable all the way through
i'm still i'm still unbearable as you
can see but the one thing i really like
well two things actually i learned from
that number one is what you said earlier
which is
you look at the media and you go even
the people who are writing positive
stories about me
are not writing about me accurately
right so what does that say about
everyone else
and what i you know and that's that that
was the moment i decided never to make
up my mind about somebody
until i'd spoken to them personally and
i got to know them
because that's such a good rule yeah i
have that rule too
because even what they post about
themselves on social media
sometimes that can come off as extremely
annoying um
and that's completely wrong too so yeah
that's a good rule
right and the second thing i learned is
i don't think our brains evolved for
that level of attention
i agree you know yeah you you're
you can be you know i'm i think
psychologically one of the most grounded
people that you could find
i found it so difficult that period of
time and it took me
months to adjust to the idea that
suddenly
you know loads of people have an opinion
about me
so i can only imagine what it was like
for your dad and for you as well by
extension just the fact that you
suddenly find yourself loads of people
have an opinion
about your your family uh based off that
while brains didn't didn't evolve for
that they really didn't
yeah i completely agree and i think
that's one of the problems that's one of
the problems with social media
i mean even a small following even
getting
like i remember when before i had any
following
you watch you know how many likes you
get on photos and you watch this kind of
thing because it's a
social metric for what people think of
you which is important if you want to
kind of evolve right but then
if you start getting i would say even
thousands
of followers like i don't even think
we're evolved to be used to thousands of
followers
let alone hundreds of thousands or
millions like
even thousands of followers you get one
negative comment
about any aspect of your life and you're
like oh well
is that true it's like who who is the
person commenting you don't know who
they are
you've never spoken with them but for
some reason the one negative comment
and then of course when you have more
followers than that then
it's literally gonna be impossible to
not have negative comments
you're not gonna have all positive
comments i don't think we're wired for
it at all and i've spoken i've been
fortunate enough to to talk to a lot of
people who have
millions of followers on my podcast and
they all had a difficult time with it
even though
their fame was let's say not as
controversial as somebody like my dad
like even just being recognized is hard
even if it's positive
and so then you know you it's funny i i
used to have more
i get it was probably jealousy to be
honest um about celebrities
it was probably jealousy but at the time
i wouldn't have called it that
uh it was just like you know it was
misunderstanding maybe i remember eminem
came out with a song a while ago and it
was like
he was complaining about the media
approaching him when he was just trying
to have
dinner with his family and he like
freaked out about it and i was like come
on
if you're gonna be famous you can't
really complain about that
and i've changed my mind i understand
that now
like it's hard like people are all just
people and it's hard to be recognized or
to have strangers approach you
um even though it can be like exciting
and positive
like i get it it's still stressful um
it's just an
interesting it's a really interesting
experience i wouldn't change it but i do
because there's not a lot of opportunity
that comes with it but i
we're not wired for it absolutely and
then you take into account you know the
type of
you know frame that you and your father
have which
you know you are figures where you know
that create a lot of strong emotions
it's different you know if somebody's in
you know like a lead swing in a pop band
where if you don't like the music you
don't listen
but everybody nowadays seems to have an
opinion whether it's positive or
negative about you both
yeah true i guess it's more politics
right like that would happen with with
people in politics
which which my dad is definitely
actively trying to avoid
it's like oh no that's weight that's way
too much
stress but i guess it's it's weird we
have this
new type of communication like podcasts
like this
and it's kind of the same thing i guess
you don't have people voting for you at
least but you kind of do i guess with
popularity
it's a weird time yeah but i i think
that
this long form lends itself to a very
different type of conversation
you know you mentioned twitter or
politics that's all conducted in these
very short sound bites isn't it and
it's all about tribalism i feel like
with conversations like the one we're
having now
you know you could be saying anything
right now i don't know what you're going
to say we don't know each other well
and i'm open to hearing it and i think
likewise you're open to hearing
what we have to say and i think that
changes the nature of it which is
why i have to ask this question when is
the world going to get your dad back
um well he's coming out with a book in
march
so i would guess around then
yeah he's not going to go full blast
but but but good yeah like
i don't think as a family we'd let him
go full blast anyway he likes going full
blast but
that might take a bit and um obviously
like i know he was touring and things
and
those are in the works too but we have
kovit
so everything's kind of on pause anyway
um
but his book's coming out in march
beyond order it's available for
pre-order in case anyone wants to check
it out
some people are going to check it out
believe me but it's exciting because i
sort of half joked the other day that
you know
jordan peterson took a year and a half
off or however long it's been and look
what's happened to the world
a little longer but i just saw him
starting to comment on things online and
i just think
a voice of sensible moderation that is
equally brave
in rejecting extremism is exactly what
we need right now so from
uh both of us and from a lot of our fans
i'm sure we
we sent him and your family best wishes
and we we look forward to seeing you
back
thank you yeah so do i so do i it'll be
fun
tonight like things will get going again
but probably
march that's exciting uh michelle listen
it's been
great chatting with you i think you you
yourself you know we obviously talked
about your dad because he's such an
important public figure but you yourself
have had such an interesting
life and i think some of the attitudes
you formed and also of course the diet
as well
it you know it's important to talk about
those things in a constructive way
because we have this conversation like
we don't talk enough about mental health
when we talk about mental health all the
[ __ ] time
you know and and just to to have a a
constructive voice on it i think is
really important so
uh it's it's been great talking to you
thank you thank you very much for having
me on i've been looking forward to it
and the one question we always finish
our interviews with is always the same
which is what is a one thing we're not
talking about
but we really should be so i already
mentioned diet so i'm going to just talk
about this isn't like
the one thing i don't have that but this
is something that i discovered recently
that's really pissing me off
um turns out my best friend
called me yesterday and she go she's
about to have a baby and she goes
i have to wear a mask while giving birth
in a private room
and i said there's no [ __ ] way that
that's a thing
[Music]
turns out it's a thing so in canada in a
lot of hospitals in the us right now
i don't know what australia is like i
don't know what europe is like but i'll
bet you the uk is bad um
when you're giving birth you are
seriously pressured into wearing a mask
the whole time
and when you're told when you go you
know i don't i'm not comfortable doing
that because
giving birth actually really hard um
you're told that
you're not keeping the people around you
safe and
that pisses me off because i had a kid
and i can't admit and that's not cool
like that's i would say that's verging
on it against human rights
especially um if you've been tested
negative and you still have to wear a
mask while giving birth
so i'm about to make a big stink about
that because
that's really not cool and i'm concerned
that
when all of this ends i don't know what
masks and when masks and hospitals are
going to end
right and currently if you test negative
or if you've been vaccinated you still
have to wear a mask giving birth
in hospitals in canada um
and i think that's like i don't even
want to be part of a society that makes
women do that
so that's what i think we should be
talking about now i don't know if it's
the big thing
but it's not cool
just as an extension to that and look
this is just an outsider's point of view
but canada seems to be going
nuts at the moment is that correct
yes i would say is correct i would say
it's correct i mean we're in on a
mandated stay at home and stayed home
order and
it's i mean the uk is crazy too
but yeah but yeah it's not it's not it's
not good here you're not allowed to see
family
you have to wear a mask giving birth i
mean right now you don't have to you
don't have to wear a mask
outside like to give our premier
some credit he's he he is slightly con
conservative so i think the pressure's
coming down on him to do these things
but i mean a mandated lockdown
yeah i would say canada's not not doing
so hot but i don't know
where is doing hot right now
i'd like to go there wherever that is
yeah we'd like to go there when we find
out as well but i i think actually
you probably meant on more than just
lockdowns yeah because
we've seen a large uptick in canadian
viewers of our show
uh really yeah so we're sort of starting
to think well maybe canada
you know a lot of people in canada are
suddenly realizing
the impact of you know all the stuff
we've we've been talking about
social justice all this woke stuff uh it
seems like
that there's a big increase in awareness
in canada over these things
and you've got the first trans-racial
premier as well which is great news
do we i didn't catch him what
what is this happening like i don't even
pay like i pay attention
i pay attention to the states and
whatever happens there
we just do five years later so we do the
same thing here
yeah you guys yeah yes you can just
slowly watch things crumbling from afar
oh god that's gonna get to us
yeah um so it's
way worse than it was in 2016 here
oh my god my um my husband and my dad
walked by
a playground the other day and it said
this is so creepy i'm not even going to
get it exactly right but i'll get part
of it
it said play fair play inclusively
that was in the playground and it's like
that is
so dystopian it's so creepy
so yeah we're definitely we're
definitely going in the right direction
well on that happy now michelle it's
been absolute pleasure speaking with you
uh where should people check out your
work your podcast is fantastic and you
although we you know you and i and
francis talked about cultural war stuff
actually you talk about other stuff and
i think it's
it'll be interesting to a lot of our
fans so tell everybody about your
podcast where they can find you online
as well
so i have a podcast that people seem to
listen to
which i can't really understand why to
tell you the truth i don't really like
podcasts
but however i i usually do some sort of
interview form and
i don't i just ask questions that i
don't
wow i'm the worst salesman for this
thing i've had some pretty good guests
on i had jocko on
had dan crenshaw and matthew mcconaughey
those were like big ones um and
we talk a little bit about health but
mostly we talk about
politics psychedelics culture
comedy like it's pretty open i'm doing a
joe rogan style
style interview i would say but it's
short an hour and that's that
um michaela peterson videos on youtube
you can just type in the michaela
peterson podcast
and my name's m-i-k-h-a-i-l-a
and then i'm michaela peterson on
instagram
uh and michaela alexis on twitter
because michaela peterson is too long
well that was the most uncomfortable
self-plug we've ever had in the history
of this show
i'm very british i that was so british
i mean i've got this podcast i don't
even like pause casting why am i even
promoting it anyway anyway let's just
promote it oh i feel so bad inside
thank you it makes them so happy look at
that that's it that's that's what's what
being british is
yeah well yeah i might have that too too
too far i've always been bad at that but
um
people do seem to watch the podcast no
it's brilliant
not only is it a good podcast you do get
some very interesting guests on
so thanks very much and thank you guys
for watching we will see you
very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one or a live stream
all of them go out 7pm uk time take care
and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below